you didn't want Olympiad to go to  matches because you were afraid you  would lose Killer Instinct  I just afraid I would get distracted  because I would be like wait is she  drinking is she doing this so she came  to a match once like super brief and I  was like oh my God is she wearing sun  cream like is she you know it's nuts and  so I would get stressed out I'm thinking  oh my goodness  wait a minute I Gotta Serve  this makes no sense so so yeah and I've  never really had her at matches until  like my last this this summer actually  and in a match where she came  she's so fun  she's coming into a match that is the  most watched moment in tennis history  [Music]  and you won the match  [Applause]